je vous propose de terminer ce journal
en compagnie d'un couple de choc et de
charme clint eastwood et catherine
deneuve respectivement président et vice
présidente du jury de ce 47e festival de
cannes
kaffrine et grint viennent de répondre à
l'instant aux questions croisées de
pascal deschamps la vice présidente
monsieur le président mais free nous
nous accorder ces quelques minutes
d'entretien entre deux projections les
deux premières ou presque d'une d'une
longue liste
alors le 47e festival de cannes s'est
ouvert hier sur une image très
sympathique celle de votre arrivée au
palais je dois dire sur votre complicité
s qui cet indiscret de vous demander ce
que vous y dit à ce moment l'intéressé
vous de prévu à rêver d un conseil
d'habitués je connais c'est quand même
assez long on vous demande de vous
arrêter plusieurs fois il faut donc
disons que c'est à la fois impatient
d'avoir une certaine contenance ne pas
être trop raide ne pas être je sais pas
je trouve que c'est toujours ça a l'air
plus naturel et c'est pas très difficile
de toute façon d'avoir envie de lui
parler dans cette circonstance donc je
ne me souviens pas exactement alors y
accueillir sur des milliers de gens pour
vous accueillir il ya eu un accueil très
chaleureux vous avez vécu des moments
très forts dans votre dans votre
carrière mais ce que vous diriez que
c'est accueilli la a été un des moments
peut-être les plus les plus émouvants
oui je le pense oui c'était une foule
très enthousiaste
oui on est toujours content lorsque une
foule comme ça avec vous pour vous et
pas contre ont justement malgré cette
cette pression de la foule tous ces
regards tous ces objectifs qui
convergeaient vers vous vous êtes il
sans doute plus détendu hier soir
lorsque vous êtes venus avec des films
en compétition terminée marché sur ses
marges d'une façon plus décontractée
une grande différence moi je trouvais la
sens si on n'est pas du tout le même
c'est vrai c'est vrai que même si
c'était un très grand plaisir
enfin c'est une émotion assez assez fort
d'être en compétition c'est quand même
quelque chose qui vous apporte une
certaine souffrance aussi parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'appréhension parce que parce
que généralement les crimes qu'on vient
présenter on y tient on est encore très
d'accord très proche de la fin du film
de la fin du tournage et que d'un seul
coup il est livré et c'est vrai que
c'est assez difficile donc je peux vous
dire que ce qui est bien et il y avait
des réactions très admirative des gens
si on veut tenue respectives ces deux
couleurs blanche et veste comme ça est
ce que vous êtes téléphoner avant de
savoir comment vous alliez vous habiller
franchement non on s'est parlé beaucoup
toute la journée parce qu'on a eu des
réunions avant ça mais c'est vrai que
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on a évoqué
non non non non non alors catherine
deneuve justement vous disiez récemment
dans un magazine un intérêt une
interview accordée à un magazine que
vous aviez refusé de très nombreuses
fois de participer à ce vêtement pour
des sots jury et que l'un parmi les
raisons qui ont pesé y avait un nom
celui du président clint eastwood que je
crois pas que j'ai dit que j'avais
refusé de nombreuses fois j'ai dit que
c'est vrai que j'avais jamais réellement
disant accepter véritablement d'être à
la présidence d'un jury et c'est vrai
que c'est le fait d'être vice présidente
que ce soit le président qui m'a décidée
parce que je trouve ça plus agréable
parce que c'est quelqu'un que j'admire
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui a beaucoup
de beaux coups d'éclat et je préfère
être là vice-présidente de quiétisme
août que d'être président tout seul
voilà je vous propose si vous voulez
bien de regarder un petit sujet qui
présente de manière assez à ces
raccourcis vos parcours respectifs
jusqu'à ce que vous vous rencontriez
non
m
il
si bien
voilà un commentaire sur cet album de
photos un peu pour le choisis
arbitrairement
c'était très beau montage et des
félicitations à la personne et la montée
tout on est acheteur vous avez souvent
l'occasion de vous voir vieillir devant
vos précieux on se voit très jeune en
tant qu'enfant mais c'était très beau
c'était très bien monté on voit des
montages rapides comme ça qui est de
retour
l'ag pack ultra rapide dans le passé on
voit des rapides vous avez dit une
phrase très jolie voulu une store ça
quelque chose de figé
elle reste épinglé comme sur un mur dont
l'imagination des gens et on finit par
en être prisonniers soient dûment déjà
moi je peux dire qu'en tant qu'actrice
on peut déjà on a tendance à être quand
même est anglais à se laisser épinglé
parce qu'il ya une façon d'être et de
cinglés qui souvent agréable aussi et
que ça a des inconvénients forcément
c'est que vous êtes vue de rester dix
ans à une certaine sur une certaine
image et que cette image est souvent
positive elle est aussi difficile à
vivre parce qu'on vous laisse pas
souvent de sortir de l'image
oui je pense souvent que vous êtes la
victime des rôles souvent avait joué par
le passé vous êtes marco stéréotypé au
début de votre carrière
ce quand vous cherchez un boulot vous
accepter n'importe quoi mais par la
suite nous chercher à faire autre chose
et si vous avez la chance de jouer à une
grande variété de rose c'est très
important
elle a joué toute une gamme de rôles
différents
c'est très bien ça et quand ils vous ont
fait les bleus nous
alors est ce que dans la perspective de
ce festival vous avez fait
l'investissement
non non ce n'est pas vrai non je vais
emporter un serveur de café
non ce n'est pas un bruit font des 90 ce
sont des journalistes de journaux de
sensations qu'ils ont dit voilà costume
du soir oui mais j'en ai fait faire
non je n'ai pas eu à les costumes
d'issoire pas du tout 23 mai pour le
palmarès mais c'était en fait merci
beaucoup merci